what's the highest you've ever slept at
almost a mile
when you don't have a fear of heights
it's not really scary it's like being in
the craziest treehouse that you can
possibly imagine
that's mark sinat he's a professional
rock climber and he's talking about
sleeping in a tent they're called total
edges that's hanging off the side of a
mountain
he's been climbing for over 30 years and
his favorite walls to climb are really
really high alpine big wall climbing is
the pursuit of scaling the biggest
cliffs on planet earth oh and here they
take a few days to summit
so he has to camp out along the way
so i want to know
what does it feel like to sleep in a
portaledge
hanging off the side of a mountain
the one thing that's
more or less ever present in the
mountains is wind
it can be pretty violent
you can experience hurricane force winds
[Music]
there's also this thing that we call the
bronco ride
wind comes in hits a cliff and it really
has nowhere to go except for up
eventually it hits you and your ledge
and it can lift the whole thing up so
you can be suspended
and then of course
the ledge like slams into the wall
you're just thinking about surviving and
that wasn't the worst of it
the smell in the ledge is not
it's not nice
you don't change your clothes you don't
bathe
it's wicked scummy
[Music]
but people love it they continue to
climb and explore through all of this
punishment
because there's still that one question
left how does it feel
the way it makes you feel is like
a tiny speck of dust
it's very empowering
it really is just like kind of the most
spectacular
spot that you can be on planet earth
[Music]